if you were to ask some people why we
have seasons they might say that maybe
it's due to how far we are from the Sun
at different points in the year
different points in Earth's orbit and
what I want to do in this video is show
you why that isn't the case so the line
of reasoning would go something like
this this is the Sun at the center of
our solar system and roughly at the
center of Earth's orbit and let me draw
or its orbit over here and so the line
of reasoning is that there's certain
points in Earth's orbit where we're
closer to the Sun and certain let me
draw a better job than that so this lets
say this is a point where we're closer
to the Sun we a little further then we
get a lot further and then we get a
little bit closer and then we a little
bit closer and then this is the closest
point so maybe Earth's orbit looks
something looks something like this
looks something like this so the
argument would go look their points in
Earth's orbit where we're close to the
Sun and points where we are further from
the Sun and actually that part of the
argument is true Earth's orbit is not a
perfect circle and there are points in
Earth's orbit where we are closer or
further away from the Sun and actually
when we are closest to the Sun so if the
earth is right over here
there's a word for that it's called
perihelion just means the closest point
in orbit perihelion peri perihelion
close closest point in orbit to the Sun
and there is a furthest point from the
Sun and this is called a fee lien or at
fili and I've somehow sometimes seen it
called aphelion pronounced up Hylian
aphelion aphelion so it is true that
Earth's orbit is not a perfect circle
around the Sun although it's pretty
close but it's not a perfect circle it
has a slight elliptical a slightly
elliptical shape and because of that
there are times in the year where we are
closest to the Sun and there are times
the year where we are furthest to the
Sun and the difference is about 3% so
it's not a huge difference in distance
I've really exaggerated the difference
in this diagram right over here but
based on this reasoning people would say
this is the flawed part that when when
we're close to the Sun this must be the
summer this must be the summer and when
we are farthest away from the Sun this
must be the winter
this must be the winter and the most
obvious point of evidence why this is
not the case is that it is not summer
when it is summer at one point in the
plan it is not summer throughout the
planet at that time in particular when
it is so let me draw our planet in
particular in particular when it is
summer in the northern hemisphere when
it is summer in the northern hemisphere
actually let me do somewhere in a in a
more warm color when it is summer in the
northern hemisphere so here it is summer
summer it is winter in the southern
hemisphere it is winter in the southern
hemisphere it is winter in the southern
hemisphere and when it is summer in the
southern hemisphere it is winter in the
northern hemisphere so the entire planet
does not experience the seasons at the
same time so that's probably I guess you
could say the biggest just point of data
that we observe on our planet why this
by itself cannot explain the change in
seasons and in particular and in
particular it does it really goes
against what we experience in the
northern hemisphere because our
perihelion right now is occurring in
January it is occurring during the
winter the Northern Hemisphere winter
perihelion right now is during the
northern hemisphere hemisphere Northern
Hemisphere winter and when we are
farthest away from the Sun this is
actually the Northern Hemisphere summer
Northern Hemisphere Northern Hemisphere
summer so although it might seem like a
fairly intuitive idea hey if we're close
to the Sun the whole plant is getting
warmer may be that summer when we're
further away the whole fit plants
getting a little less energy that's
winter the evidence we see on earth goes
directly against that in particular we
don't have the same seasons into both
the northern and southern hemisphere at
the same time and in particular in the
northern hemisphere when we're closest
to the Sun it's actually in January it's
actually in the middle of winter so I'll
leave you there in this video I've left
you just saying okay so the closeness to
the Sun does not right now does not
dictate what season we are
you're saying what is the reason and
what we'll see in the next reason in the
next in the next video the reason is the
tilt of the axis of the earth the
rotational axis of the earth